Hello, hello, Don't Getty is back, baby.
Guys, I know, oh my God, my sports commentator is a gamer.
Just, I had to do another, I had to schedule another stream
today because I just need to remind you guys that this is a
gaming channel.
I know we've been on a World Cup, it's been a World Cup
month.
but guys remember this is a gaming channel we play video
games here I got it I got give the gamers a bone before they
all unsubscribed because I realized we had back to back to
back to back World Cup watch a lot so I had to remind
everybody guys hey hey guys sometimes I also play video
games where are the sports, Toki.
Where's the sports?
Why am I here with the nerds?
You're, you're, no way.
Toki, you're, you're a nerd.
Don't say it ain't so.
My sports commentator is a fucking nerd.
No.
But any, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's so brave of you to venture outside your sports main
genre.
That is why you inspire me, Toki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You guys should have played FIFA.
We should...
We're going to try this new thing.
This newfangled trend that's going on right now.
And it's called gaming.
I've never tried this before.
It's going to be a weird territory.
I know.
It's all about trying out new things and experimenting.
We're going to be doing this thing called video gaming.
It's apparently what all the Zoomers do these days.
They sit on the PC.
Instead of watching the game, they...
Play it?
And there's no ball involved.
I don't understand how this works, to be fair.
Like, where's the ball?
Where's the ball?
What am I supposed to do with my hands?
What am I supposed to do with my feet?
Is it a kick right now?
Gwendoza, thank you.
Thank you.
This is my gay Yowie wrestling.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gus, thank you.
Of course, the word turncoat would portray FIFA and do other
things in the World Cup.
Thank you, Mr. Chat.
Thank you.
All right, let's see.
Oh, yeah.
Something I want to talk about.
But Rice, thank you, Mr. Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We made a sports beat to replay a video game for the first
time.
And this is what happens.
Thank you, Mr. Chat.
Thank you.
You know, I should have actually played FIFA.
I should have done that.
But I really wanted something like, I had like, you know, I
have so many game series.
finish and then i was just like i i wanted something more
down low more chilled in it uh get back into what video
gaming is about like i gotta remember how to play video
games so i thought what better game to do it is do it on is
a simulator game where i work at the post office like
there's no actually that's a lie everyone who's ever worked
at a post office or done like amazon stuff that's
be severely underpaid and it's like canada post has been on
strike like for more than like two years but thankfully
thankfully they're not on the strike right now so like they
called me back into work uh hey sir thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you canada post is being run by dokey
finally to have some confident leadership and the profits
will go through the roof instead of losing billions and
billions and billions of dollars you know maybe i should
just You know, let me see.
Let me see.
Guys, what if I do just play football?
What if...
Wait, why didn't I think of that?
Why didn't I just play FIFA?
I could literally just play FIFA right now.
Uh...
I thought we were out of this.
What do you mean?
Do it.
All right, guys.
Change of plans.
Wait, let me, FIFA is no, wait, is there even a FIFA game on
Steam?
Guys, all I see is FIFA is no longer available on the Steam
Store.
Where do I play FIFA?
EA Sports?
Is it EA Sports?
Wait, my fucking trick.
Who was it that gave me that idea?
Get him.
It was his fault.
I didn't even think about it.
it was chest chest gaming get him it's not called it's
called ea ea fc oh there's a 26 version all right guys i'm
down i need to subscribe okay include it with you what okay
wait actually buy the world's game edition let's get let's
get the entire countries in there like no kidding no slow
and steady guys oh shit I need to install this how many
gigabytes is this alright time to find out alright we might
have fucked up internet if I cut in and out I'm downloading
EA eSports right now get ready for 200 gigabytes of sports
and 56 gig Let's play a little bit of cat game while we're
downloading.
Can I run this?
Yeah, I'm gonna let's play it Let's do it.
Let's do a pre-show We're pre-showing we have the East Doki
log cat army limited our records are past association with
the what do you mean?
Passes I've never associated Bird they give us super chat.
Thank you.
All right, let's see is it download All right, download why
play a game.
Let's let's stretch Let's test everything right now.
All right, pre-show, guys.
This is our pre-show.
It's all right.
We're at 7%.
All right, we'll have a...
Oh, there's multiplayer?
I didn't...
If I...
That didn't show up on Steam.
All right.
Wait.
She was returning to her jock roots and were the nerds
getting bullied.
Next, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It did not say...
If I knew there was multiplayer, it just says relaxing
simulation management cozy cute and there's cats if i knew i
should play the tutorial yeah they don't even tell you
there's multiplayer how many people can you have in the cat
room does it tell you really it doesn't even tell you in the
scene description oh bringing team oh now it gets you have
to scroll all the way oh my god this could have been a
collab game I wasted this game.
I wait.
I think my thumbnail manager is awake.
Um, I need to change my thumbnail for the cat from the cat
game to what is it called?
Uh, to EA Sports FC.
EA Sports FC 2026.
It is too late.
Everybody.
Kind of strange.
would be on the other side of the counter.
Yeah, this cat in the post is not on strike anymore.
I'm back, baby.
Alright.
This is my pre-show.
It's alright.
I learned now so when we do a collab for this.
Uh, what the fuck am I?
Okay.
Hold our, okay.
Alright.
Call a customer.
Ding, ding, ding.
Oh, they should be that.
It's for my wife.
Uh, oh, why do I have this?
Discord over.
Oh my gosh, because everything reset itself.
So now I have stupid Discord overlay.
Okay, game overlay.
Turn that.
Wait, do people know I'm playing?
Okay, turn that shit off.
I hate that like everything reset itself.
Okay, enable overlay.
Enable legacy overlay.
The fuck is that?
All right.
I don't know sound guys here, but if sound guys here, let me
know.
It's part of my wife, Asher Rao Knight.
It's a big box.
I'm building a cardboard castle.
Okay.
Pick up a parcel.
Is it this?
Inspect parcel.
Is that big?
No, that's not big enough.
Wait, Kita.
It's a big...
That's a box.
It should be this.
Right?
This looks like a big-ass box.
Asher.
Is your name Asher?
Yeah, there we go.
There you go.
This is accurate.
He should be waiting like one to two hours for me to finish
this.
Okay, look at the map.
There's a map.
Oh, there's the map.
All right.
The post office has two types of parcels.
Those for Cat Island, which will be a requested account.
The box looks too clean too.
That box looks too much like a square.
There should be dents in it.
Which will be requested accounters and those for other
destination, which will leave the island.
Okay.
all right cat island in port windy i wonder if there's dogs
living on cat island or are they banned from are we like a
closed country or an open open country all right what
happens is there racism no you can't just say that like i'm
just wondering why are we calling it cat island are Are
there animals allowed in here?
Are...
Are we closed borders or open borders?
Where do...
Are...
What?
Because if there's cats, there's gotta be dogs, right?
Can you take care of that?
Yeah, sure.
Mode by pressing F.
There you go.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I might have fucked up.
That's a little bit.
Stamped the current.
That means too many.
It's too many stamps.
Stamped the correctness.
Did he want a cat?
Oh, the guy's gone.
Well, I hope he wanted cat island.
Where I put this.
I stamped it.
And that?
Oh, shit.
Where did he want it?
He wanted here, right?
Oh, I didn't listen.
I...
I didn't listen.
I went, I was like, I hope this is the right.
I don't think this is the right area.
I, maybe?
Was it the port?
Guys, does anyone read?
Just says his name.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, wait.
That is a blue.
Oh, I need four.
I need four stats.
Okay.
two three okay three three stabs but that says four all
right guys I won't get fired I'm working cat in the post
they need me guys I'm they need me I thought I stamped the
correct amount They can't afford.
They can't afford another another strike.
There you go.
That's correct.
It's literally how many more do you want?
I'm Union.
Yeah, I'm the only worker that didn't strike.
I actually came.
There's a reason why I didn't go do a strike.
What do you want from me?
It's four it's blue it's literally blue oh wait they're not
weight stamps oh i'm oh shit oh guys i let me tell you uh uh
i don't know you guys know this but um different stamps have
different meanings and as a fellow post worker uh yeah i
know i don't know you guys know that all right here Yeah,
every time customer to take your time.
Oh shit time only moves when I do a good job Where I put
this though?
I'll just put that here for now.
Oh, there's a lot see guys.
It's good that I'm playing it now.
Hello Now I like to send this okay Where would you where
would you like to send it to?
Doesn't say it just says your name All right, where would
you like to send this to?
Okay, yellow.
All right.
Yellow, where would you...
Where?
I'm here.
Oh, oh, shit.
That's this port.
Okay.
That has to be for Port Windy.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, Port Windy.
All right.
Nice.
Yeah.
Is that it?
Okay.
Boom.
There we go.
Next one.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
He fucking died.
Alright, there we go.
Let me double check.
That has to be...
Oh, that's a green.
Nah, shit.
I mean, he wouldn't notice if I charged him extra.
Like, what is he gonna do?
Like, he already paid.
He's like, oh my god, my game's done.
Alright, we'll serve this guy first.
Like, what is he gonna do?
Huh?
We're the only post office that's open.
I swear, Doki, my package gets lost.
I'll see you for all the dog shirts.
You own simple.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So that's all.
It's for my wife.
I was told that it's almost my height.
This?
Is it?
Where are the...
What is this?
No, that's for Fahad.
Where is her package?
No, that's...
I did this.
are there new packages okay her name is oh my god oh my god
all right all right whatever it's fine caramel there you go
uh the insurance can do that look i'm the only one where i'm
the only one that showed up for work i'm literally the only
one that showed up for work like they got it except this
there's a reason why i have another door you again it's
where wife demi it has this very cute sticker with a frog oh
god okay all right okay i we need a we all right guys we
might need more than one person here for this wait work
packages and the post office stops for the day this setting
seems realistic
i'm going on strike
I'm going up I'm joining the strike I'm gonna join the
strike guys
Alan thank you for super chat thank you thank you whoa Doki
what a short stream this time there's never nothing after
this bye Doki see you next time thank you with a super chat
thank you thank you I get it now.
I get it why we went on strike so many times.
I understand.
Look, I showed up for work.
At least I was the only one that showed up and did my job.
You know what?
I just so good.
I'm yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
I did such a good job.
I'm yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
That I deserve to treat myself after that.
Takes four packages, strikes afterwards.
Exactly.
Physical labor, low pay, no respect.
Post office is closed now.
Yum, yum, yum.
But we gotta play a real game, guys.
Fuck this pussy shit.
Get it?
I get it, guys.
It's time to play a real game.
A real video game.
Yeah, I'm not paid enough to care.
A fun vault.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
I'm compiling shaders.
Give me a sec.
We're compiling.
Pre-game over.
Pre-game's over.
I'm playing a real game now.
Here we go.
I don't know.
I've never played this before, by the way.
It's almost like real World Cup.
Right?
Alright.
We're playing a real game.
World Cup is not over.
It's football season.
Alright, create a new setting.
I don't know.
Jokia Bird is a baller.
There you go.
That's my setting.
Yeah, we'll get it.
We'll get subtitled.
I need to know what's going on.
I need to be immersed.
Is this a gotcha game?
I paid $100.
There's no way.
Is this why?
Is this, wait, I don't know why it's gonna connect me.
Is this why this game has mixed reviews?
I paid $100.
I thought I was gonna go around the, I thought I was gonna
have the world team.
Choose the country region of your favorite club.
What the fuck?
Uh, it went straight to England.
Of course it did.
I bet you Canada's not even included.
Alright.
I bet I knew it.
I was like, let's see if Canada is here.
Let's International Men.
What's that?
The joke's right itself.
The rest of the world.
Yeah.
Canada's the word Canada that was what's international men
and women are they not people in the countries like what
does that even mean not yet $400 came and there's not even
Canada what is international men and international women
wait I have to be Is Holland in here?
Is Holland in here?
Oh, it's just the clubs?
Oh, men's national.
Guys, where's Norway?
Oh, Norway.
Okay, I was like, they have Norway, but not.
Yeah?
Where is he?
How would it be in England?
All right, I guess we're British.
Oh, yeah, he's in.
He's in.
Which one is, where is he in?
Where?
is it we're gonna make a team of all hollands they have the
head where is mexico where is he in is it in the premier
league okay where's manchester united oh my god i'm gonna
put holland and jude in the same team i'm gonna recreate i'm
gonna recreate wait manchester united there you are all
right select the organization you wish to share your info
what can i share in manchester Oh, wait, I'm wrong,
Manchester?
No!
Oh, wait, I can go.
Alright.
Choose another club.
There's so many Manchester's.
Why are they both Manchester?
Okay, there we go.
Alright, you can have my information.
My city made it in.
Why are they even...
What's Stephen Scott Sterling on?
There's...
there's too many it's more than one it's too many all right
give me a sec let me just in case what is this called ea
sports fc 26 never mind we are still playing it's still it's
still football season
okay there you go read the info you're giving to the org
like to use your account and information to share email can
i say no oh i should yeah i'll just say maybe it's not a
good idea to share my wait but then holland will get my
information wait but maybe somehow holland would read it No,
Doki.
But, like, what if?
Bro.
There you go.
Guys, but what if, though?
Holland can read my emails.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I have the new thumbnail.
It's like we never left.
We were saddened by...
Oh.
That's the...
We'll be removed.
Oh, because he's like, that makes sense.
I was going to say, wait, they removed him.
But I guess it's like the dead man still playing.
There's a little message from...
All right, that makes sense.
All right, refund the game.
There's no...
The ultimate team.
Oh, there's Yemel.
I don't understand.
Are you ready to lead a club on and off the game?
All right, world game.
Can you take your national...
team to the victory.
Okay, we gotta create our club.
Alright.
Oh, there's a lot.
There's a lot of information.
Alright, we gotta learn how to play.
Start for beginners.
Complete drink.
Alright, let's do... Let's do manager career.
Alright, expand.
Play manager live.
What's manager live?
Was glad you paid it by just for more soccer.
Let's see.
Alright, the team weathered the pressure.
One, the big moments to finish where every club went,
looking down, ran, and looking up a success.
Step in and guide your club through a crucial summer and
turn a strong season into something even better.
Do we do original?
Or what's the difference between live and original, guys?
I won't put them I'm gonna put Jude and Holland this Berlin
Ham and like Holland on the same team I'm gonna recreate the
dream team which what do we do?
Is it live or original?
I can't tell.
Oh my god, please let me please let me press stuff I will
never play I don't know there's so many things on my screen
I'm going to
Oh, and that was just starting to middle now jump in.
All right.
I'm pretty sure our start of the game.
All right, we'll do it when the game came out.
This menu is actually fucking ass, I will say.
Play as a real manager.
I'll create a new manager.
That'll be the best manager in the world.
Then they're going to draft me to FIFA.
You know, all right.
They're drafting in FIFA.
I'll be like, score some fucking ball!
That's my strat.
Just shoot the ball into the goal.
Best soccer football coach in the world.
Who is it?
Is it Pep Guardiola?
All right.
Pep.
Key bird
I'm peppy bird Best goalie in the world Best coach in the
world What does he look like?
Wait, what does he look like?
What does fucking Pep Guardiola look like?
The very best Alright, he's bald, okay Oh shit, what's his
last name?
Okay, what's Wait, I got an idea.
Pepke will be my first name.
And then...
Uh...
Guardi bird.
Pepkei guardi bird.
Or wait.
What about like...
Yeah.
Yeah, actually guardi bird is good.
Guardi bird.
Pepkey guard, you brood.
There we go.
Okay.
Can I, like, make it?
Oh, wait, how...
How young can I be?
Oh.
Yeah.
There we go.
Whatever you do, just don't be like that simple.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
all right head where is he okay that's what he looks wait
actually all right outfits oh I can have socks all right you
can't see it I have some oh pink oh that's cute in her top
all right let's get that suit out of it oh yeah yeah I know
style and then we'll put like I'm gonna be comfy, so we'll
put a shirt under it.
We'll put a shirt under here.
Business casual, you know?
I'm here to relate to the kids.
Oh, shorts!
Yes!
Alright.
Business casual all the way.
Let's see.
We're blue.
And then facial accessory.
Does he wear glasses?
He doesn't.
But but pep key guard guardie bird does do I have a tap no,
I'm okay.
I'm good now.
I'm good I'm ready Advance
All right, what is this wait for Bruce Berusha God that
that's where he is
This is where he is I remember
Uh, I know they're in there!
I-
Wait, let's like...
Wait, but I don't know they're like currently in there,
though.
Because I need to be able to get my boys in here.
Where's Manchester City?
I don't know.
But, like, yeah, but he's at...
He's currently at Manchester City, right?
Not now.
Okay.
There you go.
This is where I want to be.
It's currently in here.
Toki, I love you.
But if you get addicted to football, your channel might die.
What happened to the cat?
I'm on strike right now.
Wait, my new title.
I'm on strike.
I joined the...
So I play football.
There we go.
Alright.
Okay, first up.
We get Holland first.
And then we get his work husband later.
How do I progress?
Alright.
Advance.
Gameplay.
Authentic allows you to swap between.
A story simulator experience.
That's closer to what you see in live.
What's compared to the classic high intensity.
I'll do.
authentic.
I'll do amateur.
I don't know what I'm doing.
What's my one out as a result of board court board expand
what the fuck?
Okay unexpected event matches let's do five minutes.
Actually no let's do six minutes your match length set full
potential quick sim match start game type weather effect.
I think this is all good.
I I don't know what I'm looking at but all of this looks
transfers active negotiation realism what the fuck all right
we're going all in i have no idea what's going on i suggest
against strict yeah i won't get fired i don't keep my
package is stuck in transit they said their only work is on
strike to play oh that sucks well maybe you should pay post
office workers uh livable wages have your ever thought about
that?
Maybe you should have paid your taxes!
Post office workers are government workers too!
Have you ever thought about that?
Maybe you should have paid your fucking taxes!
That's a key, right?
Oh!
You're dropping some real shit here!
Yeah!
Dropping some fucking real shit What's the word for some
preaching right now?
Don't keep playing the ultimate team.
I don't care who they said, I'm not paying my taxes.
Yeah, maybe you paid your taxes.
I would have shipped your package.
I'm for the people.
Yeah, truth nuke.
Oh, yeah.
Should I adjust anything?
I don't know.
The CRA sucks, though.
I will agree.
Maybe you should have defunded the post office.
That's right.
Bam!
Truth nuke.
That's right.
Remember to call your local politics to read to fund the
post office don't all right is everything good for settings
any of any actual football players here but but i'm american
stop being such a trooper the board expectation but i want
to i want to know what's like what i want to know if i'm
doing a good job where's the where's the board can't even
tell where the board is oh board all right can't be more no
sack lenient all right uh all right i'll do a lenient i can
fuck up once or twice oh five minute and a half oh yeah
workers right i think i only do five minutes all right the
referee rules too amateur is way too that's my first i've
never played this before this is my first time i gotta know
what i'm doing let's try a tax man i made love to a kitty
but not enough to pay taxes jk thank you richard thank you
thank you five minutes is actually the best guys i don't
know what i'm doing i need to start off my goal is to get
holland and jude on the same team that's that's it
yeah i don't care about anything else i need june and i need
june and holland on the same team right now all right choose
which league you would like to see simulated the same level
of details as the comp competition uh cups cop cup part of
machines will also be simulated i don't fucking know i don't
what do i want to be The same as I'm down Alright
Which is the best I guess the English one Is there And then
Holland and Manchester City Okay I suggest the league Which
league So not Not the championship Oh choose La Liga Okay La
Liga Where's La Liga Where the fuck is it There's K-League
The Spanish one Okay La Liga Oh my god am I missing it I'm
Okay Alright guys we'll find it I'm trying Oh there you go
There you go I found it Oh shit that's not you I'm sorry
it's Scotland Not you I'm blind I was looking at flags.
You know, let's add India here just for fun.
I love taxes.
I took standard reduction every February.
The government has me several hundred dollars check.
I spent on doughkeeper super chats and Zoom games.
Oh, Canadian taxes.
Rip them out.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And four.
Okay, one La Liga, Siri A.
We're Siri's A.
You gotta put the country flag with me too.
You gotta include the country flag.
Okay, there's Siri A.
And then, uh, Brun, Brun, Brun, Brun, this, whatever.
Whatever it's called.
I'm learning.
Oh, there you go.
One or two?
I'll do one.
All right, there you go.
I'm ready.
I think we got everybody.
Is that good?
I don't know.
I added India just for fun.
Oh, MLS for Messi?
All right, let's get rid of...
Sorry, India.
We're going to add Messi in here.
Oh, League 1 instead of the other English?
Oh, okay.
All right.
Is it an American League?
Oh, is it all the way down here?
Major League Soccer?
Oh, Premier.
League?
Oh my god.
Just too many.
Oh, League One French?
Oh my god, where is it?
Okay, League One McDonald's.
League One McDonald's?
Okay.
Alright.
Is this good?
I don't know if my list is good.
I have...
League One McDonald's, Bundesliga, Siri Aani-Leave, and La
Liga EA Sports.
All right.
I have Premier League right here.
League One.
All right.
Nice.
Let's go.
We got it.
It's time.
Oh, yay.
Nice.
Just bros being bros.
Let's go.
all right all right here we go all
right let's see how this goes we're loading players in i
better get holland the first draft i swear to god i spent
all my budget on holland i don't care the board can't fire
me because i said i'm i can make one oopsie uh career
manager pride live pride what i don't even know why i'm
naming the best
Hello P. Garty Bird.
We're pleased to inform you that after careful
consideration, we would like to offer you the Manchester
City Manager role.
We believe your vision aligns with our goals and are excited
about the potential our common project has.
We love you to find our proposed contract terms, which we
hope you'll find acceptable.
$83,000 per week!
Holy shit!
Guys, imagine how many dog shirts you can buy.
oh my god also i don't ever sound guys is alive i think he's
footballed up but guys it's a volume okay guys oh my god
that's a lot of dog shirts you can buy guys let me sign the
contract i won't don't need to read anything else without
further delay we are pleased to introduce your new manager
hey that's me that's a lot of super chats that's a lot of
akasupas Look at that.
I'm ready.
Who do I have?
Okay.
Mancy comes off the back of a loss against A.
Villa.
The beautiful game is back as the new season.
Ready, give it our all.
Alright.
Hey.
I'm ranked 2.
I'm already doing so well.
Alright.
Who's in my squad?
Who do I have?
Yeah.
All right, I need to trade.
All right, team management.
I'm ready to trade.
All right.
You're the weakest.
How do I...
Oh, I can't trade anyone yet.
I'll keep you guys for now.
How do I buy stuff?
Tutorial time.
Oh, they know.
You haven't done anything.
There he is.
The boss brings you a real put down.
This low-risk approach sees the team patiently defend.
Wait, is this Hirambo?
Before breaking route, this has to be Hiram, okay?
All right.
What am I looking at?
It's the best player.
Oh, okay, I want to buy.
I'm ready to buy.
That means there's a hero available for that player.
While a bronze, silver, or gold or card represents, or while
you can also see the hexagon and the top.
right corner of the card all right learn more about no
that's all right this is already a lot
guys i need to buy i need transfers there we go search
players all right we're gonna make the dream team all right
here's another tutorial searching for specific players can
be a good way to fill the gap we got a new opening
bargaining deals can be found
Players will release clauses on those while free agents can
be signed while any trial you may face a stiff competition
for these players.
All right, player name.
Jude.
I'm ready.
Get him in.
Your skill to realize that you might be interested.
I'm not interested in them.
I'm only interested in one guy.
And one guy only.
They must be reunited.
players can be scouted further until a full report is
completed ensuring the players good fit for your team is key
further pages of the report can be accessed from here all
right my fantasy yeah oh my god okay not currently get me in
here release cause 33 that's i'm good stop get him in here
I have Holland.
I don't understand.
Leave Real Madrid.
Sure listen, Vio.
All right.
A transfer hub contains...
Like, he should, like, lower his...
Lower his speed.
I literally have Holland.
Now you wait a few days.
uh have been shortlisted or who you mean or receive and from
here can be your scouts opinion how much the player might
cost as well as uh options including delegate negotiation
process to staff all right there are multiple types of deals
transfer offer a permanent but more expensive option loans
are useful to it for short term as loans to buy offer more
flexibility when your budgets i'm ready i'm ready to go all
in when negotiations begins clouds and pay your swaps can
also form do i'll give you anybody you want just give me
except for holland i'll give you anyone but holland and cost
the deal to break down entirely okay all right um approach
to buy delegate to buy i i could do the negotiation
i'm ready i don't care it's practice not even negotiation i
i'll open my bank account let you
Good to see you.
We've been looking forward to sitting down with you.
Shall we make a start?
Oh, boy.
All right.
How about...
Let's see.
Add Salon Clause.
What's Salon Clause?
I know Transfer fee.
I forgot what Salon Clause was.
It's okay.
still talking I can chat help phone a friend what if he
wants to what if he wants to swap Holland offer transfer fee
do I offer transfer fee okay oh
I sell I'm never gonna sell him I'll transfer fee all right
how much does he want how much i forgot how much he's worth
i how much is he worth is here is 500 000 all right one
million i'll give you all
right how about this i'll give you 10, oh yeah, 10 million.
Jesus Christ, how am I?
All right, 10 million.
That's about, this is going to take a while.
Just give me a sec.
Is it?
Tokey's over 200.
Guys, give me a sec.
It's going to take a while to get there.
Wait, can I just write this?
I can just write this down.
All right, how about this?
How about this, buddy?
I'll give you 100 million.
100 million I'm ready go all in all right submit offer how
was that for Jude Bellingham
what oh my god there's no way he rejected my offer
can i not please i'll do it again i'll i'll do it as reset
i'll try 40k maybe he'll accept reset i'll come back i come
back i have a new offer i have a new offer okay all right
i'll come back with a new offer can i not offer you another
i can come back in a few days i can't offer again in a week
okay maybe maybe he'll be worse maybe he'll be like a worse
player and then he'll be cheaper not the way to week what's
the point what's the point my my dream team my dream team
has already over is it that was my only strategy all right
that's fine wait can I edit players like customize a player
all right who's is this the goalkeeper oh I can't even I saw
I said I can edit him hello I can't like change their names
what's the point the jacqueline the dream team i can't i
gotta save my money not in manager mode oh okay i was gonna
all right let's see i guess let me check my emails i guess
every in your club is based on this is why we are investing
in young players in our academy we believe we can find all
of our own talent please uh please look care for the young
players we currently have on our you're responsible i can
every team that imbappe is in like did you not see him but
they have imbappe and jude and they're not doing good
together i can't have them together uh is now you're trying
to make sure we get the very best based on we feel that
abdale naren in particular has outstanding he's a good he's
a good all right to the youth academy all right obviously
has cheaply developed into the club's next generation of
style All right.
Play a new tournament provides critical match experience and
can significantly boost your development.
For the matches to take place, you have to play them
yourself.
Select the right development plan and sure they develop into
a player's two-ball for your first team.
Pro, I don't...
All right.
The White House.
Pro, I believe in this guy.
Whoa, Pace Team Marshall?
Okay, what is this?
Oh, he has shitty speed.
All right.
What's your development plan?
Using development plan and choose how you like your player's
plan.
to grow and prove it can be important to pick specific plans
since target development happens more quickly than on a
balance plan all right the speed of growth depends on how
often the player is uh playing how well they play the
difficulty of the competition they're playing in and your
coaching staff's ideal quality strong grow with speed up
over time taking for a player to improve their ovar willis
for older players it will slow their decline it's also
possible train player to be more familiar with different
positions uh do i want to fucking oh wait he's a goalkeeper
his name is white house they all suck all right guys sorry
nobody in my the dragoons don't believe in you so i guess
i'll leave i'll meet my squad tutorial or a strong happy
squad cycle three through squad information.
Sharpness and morale can significantly impact player
performance.
And their impact will be shown beside the base attributes.
Sharpness will affect physical and technical attributes.
Once player reach your peak they will grow and develop at a
much lower rate.
Alright.
Where's Holland?
Where are these people?
Why aren't you happy?
Are you part of my team?
I don't see Holland anywhere.
Where is he?
Who are these people?
Is it the ball?
There he is.
Oh, he's happy.
That's all I need to know.
All right.
Let's see.
Are you happy?
What's your development plan?
Okay, he's dynamic.
Let's fuck it.
All of these is fine.
I don't know.
I think I'm a good manager.
I think I'm doing well Tactical I'm definitely Processing
everything correctly He's happy I'm taking it all in I'm
definitely I'm definitely taking everything in And
processing everything Tactical vision uh defines your team's
strategic approach to matches it will also impact your
reputation and world and may influence fans opinions as well
as the likelihood of being offered jobs i don't want to
leave okay can we improve relevant attributes for your
players based on your head coach head coaches who are more
knowledgeable your tactical vision will improve more
attributes while your player's sharpness, depending on how
big the boost is.
Okay, I got this.
All right, this is our plan.
Your side makes full use of the width to focus on
maintaining a sharp, which will help you stay strong while
still offering.
All right, we're doing murder ball.
Where's murder ball?
All right, possession.
I think we should do possession.
Yeah!
Um, yeah everything is good wait I think I think we're good
we're gonna haram ball is this haram ball we're haram
balling yeah yeah if I can't beat him I'll join him how do I
do this
No!
Yeah!
Alright, I think we're good.
We got our plan.
Wait, player is chat.
Yeah, no messages.
There we go.
We got our tactics.
I think we're good.
I'm ready.
Alright, time to start building your coaching team.
I have to build a coaching team.
They don't just show up.
The coach with the strongest knowledge of your tactical
presets will be appointed as head coach.
U-Players also benefit from the coaching team.
Every two weeks, the coach market gets refreshed with
coaches depending.
I thought I was the coach.
Who the fuck are these people?
Ah.
Nah, shit.
This guy is 13.
Wait, what am I?
I'm possession.
Where's possession?
Okay.
Novice, novice.
I need a good guy.
There's all of them are novices?
Okay, attack skill.
We'll grab him.
With this other kind of better tactical.
Alright, no.
But DC...
Oh, wait, expert.
Wait, I didn't realize.
I didn't realize there he is.
This guy, he's an expert.
He knows what he's doing.
Alright, get in here.
Uh...
Ideal.
Put you on attack.
Do you not have five stars?
Yeah, but he's more specialized.
Wait, do we put him on attack?
Midfield or...
I feel like defense is the best for Haramba.
Right?
If it's Haramba, it's better to put him in defense.
Yeah.
I'm going to put him here.
You've had your first coach.
Alright, how have I...
impacted my game.
All right, you guys better do something, or I'll be very
mad.
You guys, you guys, I paid 3,000.
All right, hire more coaches.
I might as well.
I have, all right, set a dev team.
All right.
I mean, I feel that this is boost.
All right, all of these are okay.
I think we're fine.
All you guys Go do whatever the fuck you want.
Is that not a development plan?
I did.
I put you all in dynamic.
You guys know what's best.
You all know what's best.
Just do whatever.
I think I've developed it great.
Do whatever fuck you want.
Alright, I'm ready.
Why does it keep making me?
you're good you're good to go
all right advance all right i'm ready wait new message what
do you want when am i when am i playing on bab's whole city
i want to welcome you up good to meet you too thanks very
have a chance to work with you bernado pass on the pass on
my best to the rest of the squad too Yay!
All right.
All right, events.
I have a month until the season starts.
Okay, how many days has passed already?
All right, Thursday.
All right.
Is everything okay?
Yeah!
Party at my place!
We're winners!
That's me.
I've already won.
I'm so good.
Holy shit.
I'm so good at this.
I've already won.
Yippee!
I told you, a pepky guardi bird.
Oh my god, there's Holland.
Let's go.
I did it by doing nothing at all.
I have become...
Football.
I have three unwritten messages.
Did he not know?
I might be part of a team that I still wear to the club.
I will see a future where we'll win many more.
Alright, cool.
Please read to my agent whenever you want to talk about the
terms of my contract boss.
I like how the team is going and I'd be happy to keep being
part of it.
Alright.
I will not care.
I will.
I will now proceed to put them on red.
Can I get him now?
Alright, search player.
Jude, do you want to...
You guys... You heard?
Jude, you heard I won, right?
Dude, do you want to...
No, that's Nicolette.
I will now put him on red.
Hey, we shall advance another day.
Wait, Rodry is...
Renew Rodry's...
Alright, I'll renew Rodry's contract.
Fine!
He's not...
He's not Jude, though.
Alright, where is he?
People want me to renew your...
I guess I'll renew your contract.
I guess.
Squad Hub.
Is everyone doing okay?
Alright, let's see.
Team management.
Contracts expiring soon.
Where's Roderie?
Where are you?
You really want me to renew your contract, I guess.
Roderie?
How dare you?
Don't never say that.
Delegate renewal.
I'm start the wait.
Don't go higher.
What is your wage right now?
I don't even know what your wage is.
Fuck it.
there we go
all right except there you go you get to wait who's leaving
why are you guys leaving wait a minute why are you leaving
that's okay Holland's happy who cares about you guys
whatever Holland's happy
it's fine Holland's happy as long as Yeah, if they're weak,
I'll let them leave.
I don't need them.
I don't fucking need them.
Uh, remember as your agent, hey, don't get one, tell you how
much I love the concert.
You're singing and dancing.
We're so good.
Also, my birthday today.
Can you get a happy birthday?
Of course!
Happy birthday, Vladimir.
I'm glad you had a great time at the concert.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Vladimir.
Yeah!
Don't worry, as long as Jude and Holland are happy, we're
fine.
Fawn Blazers will be leaving.
They won't be available for selection between, uh, wait, is,
is he leaving?
Is, oh, wait, Bellingham?
No, there's no Bellingham.
Don't worry, don't worry.
He'll, he'll start doing bad, and then we are fine.
So, which of these players you wish to keep?
I need my room, Ryan, can you, uh, embrace his new
challenges, uh, new secrets?
No, I don't need to leave yet.
I don't need to leave.
How do I know whenever their contracts need to be renewed?
Alright.
You're weak.
I don't care.
It will still text me, right?
Alright, the other is I don't care.
Don't care.
Let's go.
We advance.
Is it 30?
Oh?
Saturday?
New Mexico?
message?
Okay.
I feel like I made some great progress.
Thinking about what I'm contributing to the team.
And I'm sure I should be on better wages.
I really appreciate you guys fixing up a time to sit down
with me and my agent to take a look at my contract.
I'm going to leave him on red.
Alright guys.
A new email.
Please review your new your terms.
All right, who are expiring?
Crucial?
Will it let me know who's expiring because I don't know.
When will I know?
Wait, I can get Jude.
Okay, who cares?
First off, we're gonna get Jude first.
So they'll text me, right?
If I...
Oh, I can see the financial.
Okay, first off.
Let's first spend all our money on Jude first.
Before we do anything else.
We're going to spend all our money on Jude Bellingham.
Alright.
Okay, delegate to buy.
We're going to...
Alright, they want 200, right?
Alright.
How much money do I have?
Okay, we'll start at maybe a hundred, a hundred and sixty.
Okay, and then we won't go higher than a hundred and two
hundred.
All right.
I think we're good.
Do we do it?
Did he do it?
And then we'll find out.
That's okay.
It's alright.
We just need Jude in here.
That's it.
When do they play?
When am I going to see them fucking play?
I said four years.
One year.
Zero.
Okay, he wants to talk.
One year.
Zero.
B.
Silva.
180k?
You must be fucking crazy.
Okay, eight years with Holland.
Let's go.
Alright, he wants to talk about his contract.
Open for new contract talks.
His market value dropped.
This is the game.
When do I see them, like, shoot the balls?
When do they...
start shooting I don't
know I'm not that's the you don't what's the five minute
wait a year has passed the time you started you have to
advance till next season play a game now but they won
She'll fight down.
They're not even gonna fucking play.
They're not...
What are you...
It takes a while.
I just want to see Juden Hall and play.
Oh.
Doug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is the best part.
You've missed.
Medi's ready.
See what we last stream earlier.
We give them one.
Of course.
Thank you for the super chat, Doug.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry, Medi.
I know you had a birthday during the concert.
week but happy happy belated birthday meddy happy birthday
to you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear money happy
birthday to you happy birthday
oh my god uh fuck it just let them leave i don't i don't
know if any of you guys are good i can't i'm fucking i don't
know What do you want?
All right, let's have some tea.
What do you want?
And that's what you want, because I feel like I have no
idea.
I know what I'm doing.
I've been looking after you.
Shall we get started?
Simple thank you for the super chat.
I just wanted to play football.
How am I supposed to read this?
Okay.
What the fuck are all of this?
Alright, uh, fucking crucial.
Oh, shit, wait.
It's not crucial.
Oh, shit, I don't even know who you are.
Oh, shit, I fucked up.
I don't...
Who are you?
Who...
And negotiation.
I can't.
He is a thousand years old.
Bro, he's 32.
It's at the end of it.
Accept?
Is he even worth it?
He is not.
Can I see one guy that really wants me to accept the offer?
But look at all these cakes though.
If he's not, dude, who cares?
Alright, run!
There!
I Fucking, I don't know who you are.
You're not Jude.
He did.
Sure.
Fuck it.
Guys, I'm a great manager.
Wage and signing bonuses.
What's your current wage?
all right oh my god i should not be doing this all right
well you're gonna offer you less money for more work how
about this 154.
i'm i know what i'm doing and then we'll give you
give you What was the last I don't know what am I supposed
to give a bonus for it for existing for
No signing bonuses I'm the master negotiator you know what
no I'll give you a bone I'll give you a bone Here, but how
is this?
How is this?
There we go.
Take it or leave it.
No,
wait.
940,000.
What are you talking?
What?
Counter.
A wage and signing bonuses.
940.
140 bro how about this how about this how about this
939 how about that will you be happy with that yes yeah
how about this 900 and that's so much that's a million
dollars bro like fuck that that he isn't worth that much no
he's not worth that much i i agree fuck that two dollars
how about that
780 we went to okay all right he lowered it down all right
how about this how about this
you know what you know what i think it's even more
reasonable three dollars how that what do you think about
that five hundred and twenty thousand all right all right
look look how about guys how about how this oh shit i think
three hundred dollars all right this is my final offer
That's my final offer
I don't think When do they kiss Well They go with a super
chest stick I think $10 is so much money
And that's The art of the deal
That's That's That's the art of the deal I said take it or
leave it and he took it Hey, take it or leave it and he
fucking took it Alright, I mean, sure And that's my manager
I got $10 from $990,000 taller best yells anyone to say hope
he doesn't tell the media what
great deal I told you I'm I don't I know what I'm doing like
yes I told you I knew what I was doing too much of them all
right is Silva important oh wait he's the captain is he not
is he the captain what's my team look like I don't even
remember all right squad hub I'm gonna go far with that $10
can't believe you guys doubted me oh wait we gotta keep
Silva happy right Silva's Silva yeah he's good all we gotta
make sure you're happy we gotta make sure you're right i
should make holland the captain you're so right how do i
give holland captain
development plan team sheet team management team management
i don't give him captain
jokey should be my gm for the edmonton oilers hockey team
paulie thank you for the super chat Thank you.
How do I make Holland the captain?
Have him eat the captain.
Assignments.
All right.
I'm slowly figuring this out.
I just want to see them play.
Oh my god.
Just play soccer.
I just, when will I see them play the fucking game?
I want Look at that.
I only spent 11 million dollars
Play some play some goddamn football
Where the fuck is assignments?
Oh wait, this is training.
Oh fuck now where am I?
No
Where the fuck am I now?
Alright, team management.
Asylum.
There we go.
Alright, get out of here, Sylvia.
You're not that important.
Where's Holland?
Alright.
What did I do?
What?
What am I?
What am I doing?
I need- I want you to be captain.
Oh, okay.
captain's up top oh i see all right
how do i move him though i just how do i move you up top how
do i move him up top get up there get up here
oh click the captain and select holland yeah that's a leader
if i see one all right all right now would you like to save
yes all right holland's captain now no questions asked all
right now i gotta renew your fucking contractor yes ah all
right where are you where the fuck are you all right here
you uh i'm getting someone else to delegate this uh what is
your wage Wage is 180.
180.
Don't go lower than that.
We start at 180.
And then...
Don't go higher.
There we go.
They're not willing to accept it?
They want $200,000.
That's it.
I'm going in.
I'm...
I'll do what's necessary Bro thinks he's important He's not
Jude Let him go and get Jude That's it I'm going in Alright
what is he guys Is he a prospect crucial or important He's
done Fucked up.
It's the sea time.
Oh my god, you're right.
I could sell him.
Alright.
He is crucial.
I'll put him as important.
You're sparing my...
We want him to be important peering in most pictures over
the course of the season.
Alright.
Oh, you're happy?
Yeah, you're happy.
Alright.
Contract two, you're sure.
you that sure fuck it
this proposed release clause disregard you know what i'll
propose a release wait what's the release clause again what
does that mean disregard fuck it i don't know what it does
skip that all right we're gonna skip that all right
How dare you not take my offer?
Alright, 150.
And then...
One dollar.
Take it or leave it.
Go.
One dollar signing bonus.
A million six hundred and...
A counter.
Yeah.
you're not getting that i'll give you 160 a million dollars
signing how about this two dollars take it two dollars 170
that's fine all right two million appearances a hundred okay
counter Alright.
I'll go with 170.
I'm not giving you a million.
If you leave it's fine by me.
Who cares?
I'll have Jude coming in anyway.
Here you go.
Who cares?
Jude's gonna come in anyway.
There we go.
You're not worth 2 million, buddy.
You're not worth it.
I feel like $10 seems so reasonable.
Oh, he's he after five appearances counter where where did
you get this I yeah I know he's getting angry I'm getting
angry too I get out of here just leave all right hundred
dollars that's my final I'm not just leave you think you're
gonna find a better team?
I'm true.
That's why you're not captain anymore.
You think you're gonna get a better team than this.
Leave.
And that's the art of the deal.
That's...
Holy shit.
I ain't no way.
It got me the negotiator.
How does she do this?
Well done.
In the chat, she does it again.
Alright.
I gave him a $1 million file.
Fire him before it gets started.
I'm so good at this game.
It's like an episode.
I didn't, it's fine.
I remember, that could have been 2 million.
I already fucking did everything I could.
So many Nats20s, be real.
Just like an episode of Pop.
It's that easy, guys.
All right.
What does he want?
I hate you.
I'm glad you recognize how valuable I am to the club.
It means I can clear and not focus 100%.
Let's concentrate on...
Show you're worth it.
That's right.
Now get out there and prove you're worth the money.
That's fucking right.
There we go.
Just that easy.
God, I'm so good at football.
Even though I'm not playing a single fucking game.
Am I?
Is he?
When will he say yes?
Destroy my team.
I don't care.
Okay.
It's June 21st, Wednesday.
It's 2.28 now.
Can throw a spanner in the works.
Leave of absence.
Who are you?
Alright.
Some effect in time.
Some only certain players.
Alright.
Who wants time off?
Bank dilemma.
An audit of the club.
Discovered some significant fight as a result.
What?
To.
What do you...
I saved my club.
so much money I got audited oh shit dude hasn't even come
home yet law 150 how did I get audited
I found the money ran I ran out of oil money I don't
understand We couldn't agree on terms and lie you there's no
way This cut I got I
Don't have Jude What's the point?
What's the point?
Have you played a single game of football?
I
No football hasn't played.
This is what I went on strike for.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, when do I, when do I play the actual win?
When do I get to see the simulation?
Where do I see it?
He can't even fucking negotiate for June!
Okay.
I'll contact him.
Get back this cat in the post.
Okay.
I'll swap anyone.
Who is he?
Midfielders.
Who do you want?
Oh, they're all too cheap Do I have anybody expensive?
Oh my god, all of them are so fucking You want my
goalkeepers?
I don't care
Oh yeah, I should swap Sylvia
Here, take him
And then But can I give more Okay Raji didn't offer a
hundred mil.
All right.
All right, there you go.
You get Sylvia, Silva, and a hundred mil.
All right, here you go.
Not enough!
Oh, and add Ceylon.
That's all.
It's fine.
I think it'll be worth it.
You want me to exchange Roderie?
But that's the best negotiation offer I've ever had.
No, you don't understand.
I don't think you guys understand.
Get Frodo.
Frodo?
I'll get Frodo.
Fuck it.
You can have Frodo.
I'll give you Frodo.
I don't care.
All right, and then, all right.
All right, there you
go.
I thought, do you want it?
Let them be married.
Let me have my dream team.
He's just gonna get sadder and sadder.
Oh my god.
Elevants.
I gave you everything!
It is doomed yaoi.
I'm in doomed yaoi hell.
I got second?
Nobody played.
Hello?
Oh, I won...
Oh, shit.
I won that.
Round of 16.
I won the EFL Cup.
Uh...
I got second...
Oh, that...
Oh.
Oh, we didn't even play.
Oh, I joined at the end of the season.
Okay.
Alright, never mind.
Oh, yeah, I'm second place.
I did it, guys.
End season.
I'm so good at this game and I'm willing to let you know
that port is like yeah I did it
I'm so good it's time oh my god are they actually gonna play
now am I actually gonna see some fucking football all right
it's time we're actually gonna see something happening
Oh my god.
Alright, never mind.
Okay, never mind.
Do I get paid?
Are you remaining in the club for at least another city of
Space Song?
Yeah!
Alright, now I have 250.
Okay, alright.
Nice.
We have money again.
We're gonna have money again.
Finally!
Okay, we have money again, guys.
Alright.
We'll try again.
We have money for him.
What's your market value?
You have no mark.
I'm ready.
This time.
I'll give you...
Sylvie so that I don't have to do the contract.
No, I should give him Sylvie.
So I don't have to do the contract for...
the $1 million bonus.
Just think about it.
What, at $150?
Yeah.
No, Sylvia's still here.
I literally signed him for three years.
There we go.
I'll give him this guy.
I'll give him $200.
And then...
So that I don't have to give him the bonus, you know, that
he got.
And then...
And I'll give him 200.
He's cheap because I made him cheap.
And then...
Alright, there we go.
266.
Alright.
Counter.
Okay, that's a little high.
That's...
I don't...
Okay, counter.
Can I?
Yo, I should just accept it.
No, Alex, I don't want to deal.
I'll accept it.
You can have, I'll, it's fine.
I, I, I, I've tried.
There you go.
We got it, we, that's fine.
Guys, you don't understand.
We got Jude, really.
Yay.
We did it.
We got Jude, really.
You spit it off.
Guys, it doesn't matter.
We got Jude.
All right.
Management Okay, is he here yet?
Sylvia's still here.
How do I get rid of him?
Sylvia get the fuck out.
I have Jude Where's Jude?
Why are you still here?
Wait, what but at what guys it's okay.
We got him who cares?
It's okay.
I know how to negotiate negotiate with Jay.
Oh, that's him.
All right All right We've got everything we wanted We got
everything we wanted Offer received who's he
Swap deal
Oh, he wants our goalkeeper Wait, I can get more money.
Joki, no, they won.
Oh, they won him back.
Oh, bad deal.
I don't want your deal.
It's okay, guys.
Oh, shit.
How much money do I have?
Oh.
Shit, when do I get paid again?
When do I...
Anyone know?
Guys.
Oh, he's gonna leave.
Does anyone know how much?
When do I get paid again?
Oh, I gotta sell players.
I should.
Alright.
Okay, I have to start selling bench players.
Guys, I know what I'm doing.
I just want to play.
I just...
Who are the bench players?
I can't even tell which one of you guys are benched.
Oh my god, you have 11 million contract?
Who is the shittiest one here?
Here is it.
You still want to negotiate?
All right, 11 months.
Ah, you still have plenty of time.
Self-roading?
Oh, am I replacing?
him?
Okay.
Do I add to loan list?
How do I sell him?
How do I sell him, guys?
Guys, if I sell him, I need to put a transfer list.
Alright.
You're getting sold.
I need money for him.
Alright.
Well, now that I have him.
Okay, I don't know if I should start negotiating now.
Okay.
do i okay all right you think it's worth advancing now and
then and then negotiate with him okay i'll save you're right
i don't want him i'm gonna save real quick
oh wait all right here we go all right i'm gonna see it
okay you still okay new message from froden is he mad
I'm happy part of team that added somewhere it's the best
thing for you
look he's happy again look I made him happy yeah Holland's
yeah that you noticed that yeah Holland's first yeah okay
Okay, here we go.
Wait, do I have offers?
Any offers?
Does anyone want to grab onto?
Alright.
It's time.
We're going in.
Who cares?
I think I got this.
Guys, I think I can negotiate a good deal.
Alright.
Alright, June.
I can offer you Holland.
Alright.
No, I got this.
Alright, yes, you are crucial to the team.
You are so crucial.
We need you and Holland together.
What's a good length?
Two or three years?
Two years?
Guys, I have the money.
I got to believe in yourself.
I have the money.
And I also have a save file.
I'll do four years.
He's gonna ask for so much.
I'm gonna do four years.
Oh, dad believes too.
He believes.
Alright.
He's 23.
Do we want a release cloud?
I don't understand this part.
Alright.
one it broke it's too late i put four years no disregard all
right all right your salary look dude okay i'm willing to
offer one dollar for your side for your bonus which is a lot
oh not that no shit not that look i'm willing to add one
dollar which is more More than enough.
And also.
A hundred grand.
Oh shit.
Wait.
Where did it?
Where did 30 come from?
Where did.
Where what?
Where did that number come from?
Alright.
What?
Wait, I can't go.
This is where I'm willing to go.
And I'll add a bonus.
There.
I think I have just enough for you.
I
was gonna give you everything!
But, what?
I have, dang, I was, I was gonna give you everything I have!
But that was literally everything!
I don't even know what happened to my file.
It took me a while.
You blew it.
I blew it.
Someone is getting...
It's okay.
It's like nothing happened.
All right.
One dollar and a boyfriend.
I was, I literally offered him everything I owned.
Everything.
It's rewind time.
Oh yeah, I tell him the stuff again because he's sad.
Okay.
there you go all right I'll advance again I can negotiate
with him again okay I got an offer I got an offer offer 67
wait is that enough it's wait how much are you worth I don't
remember how much you're worth Froden all
right I can get it.
Negotiate.
All right.
No, I think this is the perfect number.
Really?
That's their entire yes, but negotiate.
But what if they take it away?
Fucking we boss squeeze them.
You're right.
I'll negotiate.
I could get it.
something better and we ask for more okay
i need i do i need it for beltingham i do
any for anything for jude eight million okay okay propose
new transfer fee i would like that's
my final offer that's my final offer
yeah nice I'm happy with this I'm happy with it nice
negotiate With what?
I already got you.
I already lost.
You already got.
Okay.
Or my goalkeeper.
Oh, I already broke down.
Wait, I can pay him now.
It's fine.
I got what I needed.
This was better than anything.
Alright.
there we go all right this is it all right i think you pay
him now all right
wait do i have the money yet oh fuck i i thought i got the
money already oh fuck
oh shit okay Ah, give me out!
Give me out!
And negotiation.
I...
I'm
not gonna...
We just ended.
Abort, abort!
It's rewind time.
Do it.
Abort, abort!
All right, here we go.
All right, all right, all right, all right.
It's rewind time.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, I'm learning.
I'm learning.
All right, here we go.
All right, now.
All right.
Wait, where is he?
All right, I've...
I'm putting you on the other team.
I don't know why I'm negotiating anymore.
I've lost track.
I don't even know what I'm negotiating anymore.
I...
Alright.
Can I just...
Leave?
Can I just ask him to leave?
Can I just write...
End negotiation right now?
End it goes straight to June?
No.
I have to accept it.
Oh my.
Oh, accept.
Oh, I need to sell him.
Commerce, competitive placement is like a promise clock.
All right.
Fine.
You're not that important to me.
You're not Jude.
I don't care.
But if you start off, if you start winning a million
dollars, I swear to God.
I don't fucking know.
That's my offer.
Will you get insulted?
It's rewind time!
I thought it'd be a funny joke!
No!
Did I get the money?
Oh, fuck.
It's rewind time.
I know I fucked it up, Dad.
I don't...
I couldn't bring it.
It's okay.
I don't think you found it that.
funny I just want dude on the team all right give me a sec I
give him something I
thought it was funny I thought it was funny I got new email
okay that's my fault This is the strangest dating sim I've
ever seen.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the...
Magenta super.
Alright.
I just want him to play like one game.
That's all I want.
I can't even fast forward this.
Alright.
Okay.
What does he want?
Oh my god, he's different now.
It's sporadic.
I don't fucking know.
Alright.
Shall we sell him like my clients looking for a two-year?
Yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
His current wage is 60,000.
Alright, 50k.
Yeah, that's fine.
I'm good with that.
I'll give you 50k and a $1 signing bonus.
I gotta save money
50k You're not that special kid I don't even know who you
are There we go How about that?
One dog What?
Who are you?
Who the fuck are you?
Are you to be like, no?
Wow.
You're being transferred to Manchester City.
What did the other team give you?
Guys, it's rewind time.
You should be happy to be in Manchester City.
He's a John Clark.
Being under the team is already a hundred grand.
It doesn't matter what your name is.
I have no more wages.
Who do you think you are?
All right.
60k.
You were just here to help me get money.
I don't care.
Yeah, I, in fact, you should be playing for my, for, for my
team for free, just for exposure alone.
You should be happy with the exposure.
I don't remember what he wanted two years.
Four of the five.
Yeah, you're nothing.
This team is Holland and Jude.
Yeah, you should be paying me 60 grand for putting you on
the bench.
All right.
Yeah, yeah, you should be paying me just for the fact that
he gets to sit on the fucking bench.
Five.
No signing bonus.
Done.
You don't even get a signing bonus.
Are you serious?
You're looking for a 430 grand?
You're not getting shit from me.
Who do you think you are?
That's all I do for you.
Alright.
Get out.
Get the fuck out.
of my office.
You think I... You want 430?
Get the fuck out of my office.
Actually, get the fuck out of here.
Alright, we got it.
What?
There we go.
Not of the deal.
They always take the one dollar.
Alright.
And save overwrite this.
okay do i have all right i still have time all right i still
have time oh
no it's rewind time it's it's rewind time it's
okay all right Okay, we can still have... I don't have
money.
I...
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh, I should...
Oh, when will the money come in?
No.
Okay.
No, no, no, no.
It's gonna...
How much money can I do?
How much money can I do, technically?
Wait, I think I get paid.
I think I get paid today.
Is that enough?
There we go.
Okay, everything's fine.
Everything is fine.
Did I get paid?
I can't tell.
I can't tell!
Alright, Christopher, thank you for super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, they'll email me.
Alright, okay, I still have time.
all right I have 10 I have 9 days I have 8 days 3 offers
what are all of these
Newcastle United once I don't even know any of you guys
can I get more money I can get more money to get over this
right
all right I need more money I'll negotiate more I think I
can get more all right they want wait actually they want
36,000.
I don't need Lewis, right?
Okay.
How much do they want?
24.
Alright.
Give me money.
I need money.
I need more money.
I need to make the Jude team up possible.
The Jude Holland team up.
Christopher, thank you for the super sticker.
Thank you.
Alright.
I want 24 grand.
I want 24?
Alright.
I want that much.
Actually, I could get for more.
Well, I could get more.
25.
Ask for, like, 30?
You're right.
30.
I want that much.
I install?
Wait, how much?
21?
Alright, how about...
counter counter
23 how
about that 23 69 69 69 Salvi thank you for the red thank you
thank you that's your final offer alright alright how about
alright what about this what about this
I can't go less than this.
I can't.
Yeah!
I'm fine with that.
That's fine.
All right.
And that's the art of the deal.
I became expecting to see soccer and a deal or a no deal.
I've been thinking of the super chat thing Thank you, the
$1, Gavin.
Guys, I think...
Guys, when does the soccer part start?
How does she do?
Guys, when did I play?
I'm doing all this for five minutes of football.
Oh, no.
We're five minutes of football.
We won, Ray.
I fucking, who the fuck cares anymore?
Just take me to the next day.
I don't.
Oh, wait.
That's the sort of state.
It's a super new...
I wouldn't understand.
Okay, but do I accept this?
Oh, whatever.
Who cares?
I don't care about you.
I just... The mo... Oh, my God.
It's a slow burn.
This is a...
Oh, my God.
This better be a good email.
I swear to God.
Get out.
Leave.
We need...
We don't need another bench warmer.
Leave.
Who tricked Doki and playing an idol magic game?
All right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I have 21.
All right, bad negotiation.
I could have got $31 million.
Yeah.
.
I just I just I just want Holland and Judy
Why won't he come home does he not want to play with his
husband
Why won't he come home believe.
I don't want you!
You pop us through.
Thank you for the sewer chat.
Thank you.
The one that got... Yeah, you're not June!
Your poor man's June!
Sometimes we cannot change the face.
You want to play with the dictator!
And then
Yay!
Excellent deal!
Tap.
It's alright, guys.
I got a great deal.
Do I have enough money now?
Maybe?
Maybe I have enough money.
I mean, if I could talk to him, he's surely, surely the
dude.
Is he inside?
Who's he with?
Who are you with?
You're already in another team!
I spent so much money getting you out of that team.
I spent my entire...
I get my money back, right?
Wait, now I can sign him, right?
Oh, okay.
This is it.
I didn't save, guys.
Okay.
We're back.
We're so back.
We have the money.
All right.
Here's the deal.
I give you Sylvia.
you and then I give you 200
all right is that good
all right
is that good enough you're right 215 okay you're right
you're right just in case he rejects it I'm too scared it
up.
Alright.
2.10 and silver.
You can't be insulted.
That's... I'm offering you silver.
Oh my god.
Good business.
Alright.
Okay.
Now.
I should have enough to pay him.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's take a seat.
Good deal.
All right.
You are crucial.
You will be played no matter what.
Husband and husband should be together.
No matter what.
Accept.
That's fine.
Girl, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
How long?
Four or five years.
We gotta reunite them.
This is all that is.
Five.
Okay.
Okay, five years.
All right.
I have the money.
How much does he want to be paid?
just just tell me someone data mind this 500 and fuck it
yeah you want it you want it someone data mind how much does
he want quick he wants it I don't care
I didn't
It's fine
It's fine Who's gonna buy him?
I'll say no He'll never Want to leave Okay 200k
300k How much should I give him?
Guys
It's fine I'll have have him for one day.
That's enough for me.
That's enough for me, guys.
I'll have him for one day, and I'll be happy.
You know what?
You get it.
I'll give you 69.
good enough at
least 400k is that what the data miner says all right how
about this you should be happy with this right too low how
about this you better be worth it All right, 420, my final
offer.
There's no way he's going to get pissed, right?
3 million and a murder bonus if he hits...
All
right, no, I...
I'll say I'm excited.
I can't.
I can't risk it.
Okay, all right, I'm...
Yeah!
Think of the...
Yes!
Think of Holland.
Oh my god, just take it.
Just take it.
Just say yes.
But as well...
Oh, he did it!
I like he did it!
We're gonna have a wedding!
Yes!
Love finally wins!
A couple Bigger co-op.
Now that's a deal.
The most extensive.
Yeah, Pelagel!
Don't keep back up the season in the first week.
And it was worth it.
Yeah!
Get the fuck out of here, Sylvia.
I got all...
I got Judah Pelagel.
for a great price She'd take this huge budget of new star
player
Get in fellingham who do I swap?
Where are you get in here fellingham it's time What do I
even swap you with
All right
Church key.
All right, get out of here.
Oh, yes.
Guys, screenshot this.
I have Holland and Billy.
And that first, thank you for the second chat.
Thank you.
It's beautiful.
It's real.
We did it!
And they're next to each other!
The dream team.
I made it happen.
Oh my god.
Yes.
I made this happen.
I've done it.
It took a lot of sweat and tears and relief.
five why my ship is real oh my god we fucking I don't care
what happens maybe we'll play a game now maybe maybe we
withdraw our offer but he got sold What do you mean?
I sold him.
All right.
Okay.
Now we should be playing the game.
All right.
Which one do we accept?
Oh my God.
Which one do we get the International Cup?
The Champions Trophy?
Or the Asian Elite?
Oh my God.
Do I get to play the game?
Do I...
dessert.
I'm yum yum yum.
I this is my bonus today.
Um yum yum yum.
All right.
Invitational.
Well, this has the most Asian has the most invitational.
All right.
Do I get to play?
When do I play?
When do I I don't care I From Manchester United Alright is
this a good offer Does he matter?
I don't know
Do I just ignore everything Reject?
Alright, reject offer Not good enough Not good enough What
do my emails say?
Alright, who cares?
I don't care I just want What?
One game.
I'm not selling.
I don't care.
Oh, shit.
82 million?
Who are you?
Oh, don't sell him.
Reject.
All right.
I'll keep advancing until it happens.
Where are you?
What do you want?
I'm ghosting him
I'm gonna ghost him Yes Oh my god Let's go Alright Okay For
more personalized Alright Gameplay type How's he at top down
the entire pitch while quick play instantly gets to the end
result.
Then use the tactical view to see the match.
Show you the most exciting part to attack.
Give you the best bite.
Oh my god.
Oh my is this a game?
Is this a no.
Wait I have to play the actual game.
Wait.
Wait, wait a minute, wait, I thought it was a simulation.
I, wait, you two.
Wait, I want, two can play.
I want to watch.
Guys, I want to, I don't want to, like, I don't think I,
guys, I'm going to lose.
Guys, we're going to lose.
It's a tactical view?
Which one is it?
Alright.
Wait, watch.
Do I do similar tactical view?
What?
Come on.
Alright.
You put a tactical play.
I don't know how to play.
this game I care I spent so much money on felling heaven
Holland I want them to win I all right don't next I spent
too much money you want me to fucking work for this all
right
team as well as for the manager and all eyes are firmly
fixed on the newcomer all right here we go back today or
might the weight of the occasion prove too much i have the
power couple to find out live on ea i'm a manager all right
do your thing so often running here at the first half
starting 11 for manchester city all right this is classic
dynamic oh my god it's like i'm watching football right now
again i'm doing watch party again it's all right it's
passing that way you're doing what what are you doing you're
passing the fucking passing the dude what the fuck are you
doing
Why?
I spent so...
What are you doing?
Fucking take it.
And you're letting him fucking fuck you up like this.
Seal it.
Die.
Oh, nice.
Good pass.
Give it to Jude.
Give it to Bellingham.
I spent four...
Oh, my God.
Yes.
The boyfriends.
They're working together.
Pastor Holland.
He's right there.
Holland is right there!
He's...
Shoot the fucking bombs, dude!
Shoot!
Oh,
my corner kick, corner kick!
We got the corner kick.
That's me.
I keep it quiet.
The cat is still playing versus 11.
The title has to be there, right?
Oh, you're watching from the television now.
End to end.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I could target this.
Where's my boy?
There we go.
Holland.
Holland, let's go.
Oh, my God.
All right.
Pass it.
He's right there.
Who cares about the player debut oh my god holly's got the
ball go ref yellow card yellow card
oh my god oh my god i swear to god i'm gonna sell one of you
i'm gonna sell one of you where are the fouls where is
anything Guys, what is the referee's bank account routing
number?
I still have $1 million left.
Are you...
Oh, God.
Good save.
Dude, something.
I just need to buy the referee, too.
All right.
Are you fucking kid?
Good head, good head.
Good head.
I don't think the 4-5-1 is worth it.
What do you mean?
It's worth for every other team.
Oh, my God.
Yes, Holland.
Yes.
Oh, oh, take the shot.
Take the fucking shot.
Yes.
Holland, take the shot.
Holland, why are you passing?
This isn't your job.
This is an inaccurate AI.
This AI is inaccurate.
What the fuck do you mean he's passing?
Holland does not pass.
Holland and Ball.
Holland shoot goal.
All right.
Good pass.
This simulation is inaccurate.
All right.
Bellyum's got it.
Bellyum, pass it to your fucking boyfriend.
I spent so much money on you.
my god why are you okay third okay yes
you said it to haramba i didn't think he would actually do
it i didn't they nerfed his viking stats
all right all right nice nice good good haramba good haramba
where are my yellow cards where the fuck are my yellow cards
How dare...
Oh my god, nice, nice pass, nice pass!
Alright, that's enough passing.
This isn't...
Oh my god, the boyfriends are playing together.
Are you kidding me, Bellingham?
This is why England lost.
This is exactly why England lost.
Are you kidding me?
Okay, good D, good D.
Alright, maybe our good investment in defense.
Investment in my fucking boyfriends in the boy.
Okay, Holland, push him.
Holland, I know you can you have the fucking Energy you can
push him Oh my god
Toots Now toky is a wrong volley One shot and zero goals.
No wonder no one No wonder they sold you to me.
No wonder.
This is how it feels to play Uma Musume.
Alright.
Alright, we gotta decide on something.
Team management.
Alright.
We gotta change our tactics.
Alright, we gotta change it all.
Park the bus.
Oh, that's Haramba.
Alright, we're gonna...
Which one is high aggression?
Which one is it?
433?
Oh, wait.
No, okay.
Alright, what do we want?
High pressing?
There we go.
High pressing.
433 attack!
Right here!
4-3-3 attack.
We're going all in.
This is it.
Alright.
I'm good.
Alright, we're good here.
Alright.
We need to sub anybody out.
I think we're good, right?
this has to work i don't think you guys need to be subbed
out you're fine all right resume match
all good all right go back in
this is it now now you can push him now you can push him
holland push him i give you my permission
All right, there we go.
Oh my god, now they're Haranbali.
Holy shit, what are these?
What are these cams?
Oh my god, I don't know what's going on.
There's too many cameras.
Oh my god, what am I looking at?
There we go, classic.
There we go.
All right, Holly, you got the camera.
You know what to do, Holland.
Oh my god.
Why are you still passing?
Why are you still?
Yes Yes, I'm gone
Yes Why are those yeah, yes Oh, we did Well, here's the
replay he does well to find that bit of space in the box and
then he shows a lot of complaints Um, I'm a genius.
I'm so good at this A goal!
A goal!
This Holland's running?
Unrealistic.
It's not Holland.
I'll take what I can get.
Quick goal.
We did.
We do need it.
We did need that goal.
Oh, danger here.
Alright.
It's fine.
Good deed.
To make sure nothing untoward happened.
he hugged the wrong guy it's okay it'll make him it'll make
Bellingham jealous so he'll play better that's the plan he's
not hugging Bellingham oh my god push him Holland you have
my permission just eat him oh shit push him rush up grab him
yes yes all right we request a sub no we didn't we don't
need a sub head head oh my god you're tall enough for this
oh but yes
and sim yeah I know this guy hey and you best guys on my
team I got that guys on my team all my guy.
He's a guy.
He's a pro.
That's right.
He's on my team.
Maybe Haramba was not it.
Maybe my team was not meant to play Haramba and didn't even
hug.
They don't want to make it too obvious, guys.
It's a slow burn.
You know?
It's a slow burn, guys.
more minutes unless they pull in argentina we're fine okay
all right nice nice okay that's just that's not a corner
kick we got parked the bus for 40 minutes i don't think i
can adjust the strat yet where are my files just oh nice
deal nice deal nice deal i get egypt unless we get egypt we
okay everyone's okay all right nice oh come on sorry nice
head all right i got to change the camera angles what are we
doing what the fuck was that pass it's okay they're not
stopping the reps not listening nice oh it's a quarter kick
that's
that's okay we don't need a sub i'd rather die on the field
so we can stall time
they can just die on it's okay it's good stall dying on the
field
that's more time to waste for us nice fast he passed his
boyfriend oh okay it's fine it's fine That's fine.
That's okay.
If you need to, I give you permission to punch your
teammates.
Yeah, use the corpse to block a corner kick.
Good pass.
What was that?
I should have sold you.
I should have sold you when I had the chance.
What the fuck?
Okay, never mind.
Never mind.
You're good job.
Good wasting time.
Good job.
You did great.
You're doing great.
I know, what the fuck was that?
Nico Gonzalez.
To take it away.
That's really good awareness there.
Plenty of support here.
Alright.
We got the television broadcast.
I've been television broadcast as best.
It's like I'm actually watching the game right now.
Ten more minutes, guys.
Ten more minutes.
Don't make me sell you.
You know you're all.
All of your expendable except for Jude and Holland.
Oh, look at it!
Yes!
I got it!
Oh, God!
Let's go!
Oh, this is my new ship.
We did it.
Three.
Oh, there's no coming back.
There's no coming back from this.
Let's fucking go.
They live another day.
This team lives another day.
No upside.
You see, the ref might have, I used our budget very well.
Don't worry guys.
I made sure I spent my money wisely.
Look at that.
I am the best manager.
Saul, I don't care.
Saul, all you want.
You ain't getting three goals.
You don't care.
Have a goal.
Have a fucking shoot it.
Mike, I should have been playing it.
I wish I could toggle.
Oh, look at that.
I wish I could toggle and just be like CS where I could take
control of the bot.
I take control of the bot and then like just right here and
just walk away from the goalkeeper.
Wait, I can.
How do I do it?
Jude Bellingham.
How do I come in?
No, it's too late.
Oh, if I pause and jump in.
I should have done that.
I should have paused and then like just walk away from the
goal and be like, I'll give you one.
If I knew, I would have done it.
What we got was more of a solid performance.
I would have done it.
You know I would have.
I didn't know.
Yeah, Bob's last second of the joint.
Look at that.
I'm a natural.
I'm a fucking natural.
I'm so good at football.
Look at that.
Let's see.
Final scores.
Oh, I think I've done the best of everybody.
Oh, my God.
I'm so good at football.
Alright, guys.
I won a game.
Let me save.
I don't want to use it on...
Alright, we'll see what it's like.
Alright.
I win.
football all right we
did it guys we fucking did it all right how do I all right
I'll play one game use the controller I don't know where my
controller is that's the problem I don't know where I played
it all right how do I play one game I managed the world's
game We're going to try Oh, there you go Quick matches,
there we go Many ways to play Kickoff, track your stats Live
Kickoff, then Kickoff game Alright
So this Legendary players
Cup Finals I want to replicate the World Cup
top clubs rush is there a world cup I won't be Canada
where's World Cup
champion league oh they don't have license to champion
unlucky one off just the start one off field attention and
it's just one game away let's do it let's get the finals in
all right all
right i'm canada
all right
uh manchester city with canada let's go let's there you go i
don't know where my controller is Wait, wait, I have this
one.
Wait, I actually have a...
I'll use this controller.
I was around...
I have a Nessie controller that I got as a...
I don't know what I put my actual controller.
The Doki Bird controller right now.
Thank God.
Shout out to Apex for sending me a Nessie controller.
Spiritually, finally.
I can be Canada.
Alright, who's the weakest team?
Wait.
randomized all
right oh shit do I have a cable all right let's see is that
is this a cable gosh shit I need to find a cable I don't
have a cable no that's a problem too fuck
the cable oh this is bad I don't have what's PS what's PSG
is that the weakest team okay no I want to be that I want to
swap the other team I'm fine maybe I keep randomizing
alright okay there you go
oh they're all insane which is the weakest out of all of
these which is weaker i don't have a lot of options there is
a world cup game mode it's called uh world game and it's
majority yeah but i don't need to do a one app i'm not here
to play entire set
oh france okay
who was it psg france sg paris st germain all right guys let
me see if i can find a cable for that's the only thing I'm
missing I don't have I don't know where I put all my cables
my like controller cables I don't have any give me a sec let
me say I could find one
I have a cable, but I don't know if it'll work.
This is a table that got wet when I actually spilled water
my bag during Anime Expo.
So, oh shit, I don't even know if it's...
Let's see.
All in.
Oh.
Lit up.
Oh, shit.
This is weird.
too all right okay it's weird because it has like back
pedals not used to it oh my god I can't hear the game
because it's like is it on the controller where fuck is the
volume at oh my god it's on the controller
I don't want to hear any oh there we go all right
Paris SG is so strong guys wait why is Paris SG so strong
why you liars they're weaker what do you mean wait
I wait let's let's fight Netherlands let's guys All right,
Netherlands.
We're gonna...
All right.
All right, Netherlands.
Congratulations.
I'm...
You get to fight us.
All right.
This is bullying.
There we go.
I don't get...
All right, we're good.
We're going to try this.
Call it.
Don't bring our skills.
At the end of the week, we suggest a difficulty.
All right.
Imagine losing to the...
Start your predictions.
I don't know how to play this game.
I've never played this game before.
The most prestigious club competition in European football.
And now it comes down to this.
I can't believe Netherlands made it.
Who will prevail?
Oh, there's Holland.
I Can't believe it.
They did it.
What's the poly market prediction guys?
What is it?
How do I play this game?
Are they not gonna teach me?
Am I going in blind?
How do I shoot?
How do I pass?
Where am I?
Why am I going?
Why am I going this way?
Where am I going?
I
I don't know I'm like a troll like I don't want to move Oh
my I'm down It's my mouse and keyboard Oh my god It's
because my mouse and keyboard is but
Okay, it's fine.
Yeah, I'm using mouse and keyboard.
It's fine.
No, what's going on?
What?
I don't...
Why is it a mouse and keyboard?
Why is it?
Okay, wait, I turned off my mouse.
Maybe that will work.
Turn it off, my mouse.
I turned it off.
It's still biting to the mouse!
Why is the goalkeeper?
What are you doing?
Oh my god!
Why are you shooting?
Okay, I paused to like...
Oh shit, not that.
Oh my god, okay, okay, let's get this out of here.
Okay,
okay, okay, there we go.
There we go, we're back.
We're back, we're back.
There we go.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, shit.
That's not what I wanted.
No.
How do I pass?
A pep cardiola!
I believe it's a comeback.
Okay.
Alright, we're good.
We're good.
Let's go, Holland.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
I hope...
I'm passing I'm passing here you go shoot shoot no okay it's
fine let's go pass pass where are you going oh god fuck
Pass!
Oh boy!
There you go, there you go, there you go, there you go,
there you go.
Pass!
Shoot!
Oh!
What?
What put in this shoot?
What put did I pass?
This is the one time I do not need you to pass what button
to shoot
Oh my god
I'm slowly learning no, no foul no foul no foul I look at
the men It's fine.
That's fine.
It's just one yellow card.
Better hotels are hard to say how it thinks for making me
rich.
Caladria, thank you for the super...
How is that a foul?
Oh, thank you.
Thank you for telling me how to play it now.
I didn't... Nope.
Nope.
Plenty of support to you.
All right.
There you go.
Shoot!
Ah, shit.
Pass.
On a time for composure on the ball.
There you go.
Pass to him.
Pass.
Shoot.
I'm pressing squares and circle I don't know I'm just doing
square I don't know what other moves I have squares and
circles can I do anything else oh shit
Yes!
Ya!
Fall down!
Doff!
Again!
Yes!
Yeah!
Let's go!
Again!
Let's keep doing it till it goes Yes!
A goal!
I told you that's how I just keep it passing what is squares
in what the fuck is square following the goal that made
things level there we go
oh my god shoot no got a corner corner corner pair crosses
okay all right I did it all
right aim the camera to pan it add spin to position then
power your cross what the fuck that I don't fucking know am
I doing it okay no foul no foul pass could be dangerous
power shit
There you go.
That's fine.
Go again!
That's a corner.
If I hold it, it becomes more powerful.
Another corner!
Yeah, we're learning!
all right
oh come on punch him there you go no no kick him kick the
goalie kick the fucking goalie
oh yeah that's looking right there you go good pass oh good
pass no I don't know what I'm doing.
What?
Oh shit.
There you go.
Yeah, duh!
I wanted, I don't know, I took the risk.
I took the risk.
It's okay.
It'll work eventually.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Just keep going.
Pass it.
Nice!
Pass it!
Come on!
Come on, Holland!
It was a clear shot!
It was such a clear shot!
Too hot.
You can't pass forever.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Yes, corner.
Too strong.
Gotta control it.
He's too strong.
Oh, now, don't come on.
They have more room.
All right.
Well, now I know I can get closer.
No, she got a foul, foul.
Oh, come on.
That's it.
Yes.
Are you serious?
No, it's okay.
Half time.
It's okay.
We're figuring this out.
Look, I gave them a freebie earlier guys I gave them a
freebie who cares it's fine I figured it out what it's a
close game I trained you guys I purposely gave them that
goal earlier but I it was on purpose or it would have been
too much it would have Oh shit.
All right.
Pass to the Holland!
That's right!
Shoot!
The Holland!
What the fuck?
What the fuck, Holland?
He shot.
I swear to God.
I swear to God, Holland!
Ha!
Okay.
It's fine.
You don't need subs.
I'm pressing it to a lot.
Well, now I know.
It's fine.
It's not fine.
That's fine.
Pass it.
Can't do that forever!
Oh my god, they can.
They absolutely can.
They absolutely can do this forever.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Yes!
Ah, go!
Ah, yes!
Wow, do that flip.
Yahoo!
They did it back.
Yeah.
And that's how you play football.
Let's go.
I got...
What a pass.
What a fucking pass.
Alright.
We don't need subs.
They're all fine.
Everybody's fine.
Wait, maybe you do.
Wait, I should have subbed him out.
I forgot you guys the yellow card.
That's right.
Whoa.
I'm gonna run all the way in unless I pass.
Oh, I didn't expect that, did you?
And I passed again, and then, oh, what do you mean, offside?
What do you mean?
Who was it?
That does not count.
Vard didn't exist yet.
How am I spawn camping?
That's something eat them.
I'm going to eat you.
Oh my god.
Save it!
Yes!
Get it.
Pass it!
Pass it, Holland!
Pass!
Okay.
You're out in town.
Come on!
you can run oh i can run with r2 imagine this game god why
how do you miss that's what i'm saying oh my god no no no no
no no we don't keep going nice like you i'm gonna sell you
what
how did you miss that Holland how did I get a red card
that's a very fine piece of tackling I don't Holland I'm
gonna sell you Holland I'm gonna sell you Holland all right
the That was a tap!
That was a fucking tap!
Nice.
Oh, it's fine.
Fucking, who cares?
There you go.
Fucking,
you're just going to score.
You're just going to score it.
Fucking...
It's too high.
You're just just shoot the bomb.
Ain't no way.
Oh,
because I am using the sad part is I am using a controller.
Why?
There we go.
Pass it.
Oh, my God.
Holland, how do you know I'll fight again?
How do you fight?
There you go.
Are you serious, Holland?
Just so, Holland, Holland, Holland.
Holland, Holland.
I'm just going to tap it.
Holland, Holland, Holland, Holland.
That!
Holland.
Guys, I just need you guys to know this is the first time
I've ever even, I didn't even look at any of the tutorial,
guys.
You need to know, I'm learning this as we go.
I'm figuring out the controls, as this is my first game
ever.
I'm figuring I don't know what any of my controls are.
I'm just pressing button.
Guys, is it obvious that I don't know what any of my...
Hold it!
No!
Punch him!
Kick him!
Kick the goalkeeper!
I don't care!
Just get a yellow card!
Just kick him!
I will...
I give you permission to kick the goalkeeper.
I...
...
All right.
That's okay.
Corner kick.
Versus three hours.
Guys, I don't think you realize I was stuck in management
hell.
I was stuck in management hell.
I don't think you guys realize how long I've been being...
I've had...
Oh, God.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
timely defending when it mattered all right okay
fucking i held it i
there we go wait what does triangle do what does triangle do
i don't even know
Okay.
This is it!
Round five!
That's it!
It's a through ball?
What is through ball?
Oh, pass through like a long pass.
Okay, long pass.
Okay.
Let's see about the delivery.
Okay, the ball is better.
Yes!
I like you!
She did it!
It's cannon!
We got the cannon!
The cannon goal!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Sub that man in!
We did it!
Oh, that's a beautiful!
What a beautiful god!
Who's it?
Yeah, Calandria!
happened to betting on the until you didn't believe you
didn't believe w head w head from holland w head he's not
being sold
oh my god i ran through him right oh there you go there you
go all right i just go just Go Holland!
Just go!
You're so much faster!
Okay, I didn't tell him to shoot.
That was a mistake.
I did not mean to do that.
I forgot my controller has back pedals, so I accidentally
pressed the back pedals are the shooting ones.
I didn't realize that.
I've been actually pressing the back pedals.
I was like, I did not press it, but I realized I pressed the
back pedals.
Five minutes to go.
Good head.
Nice head.
Darling, why?
How?
I didn't.
I just press circle.
Holland, please.
Holland.
You scammed me on a mouse.
I'm staring at Teddy Rape right now.
How dare you?
That's right.
You got baited.
You got baited because my mouse was plugged in.
Don't keep, please.
You got baited.
You thought.
Oh, my God.
Oh, shit.
There we go.
Pass it to Holland.
You don't know what to do.
Pass it again.
Oh, corner, corner, corner.
Oh, that's it.
I didn't slow down okay okay I can't help it I'm gas gas gas
gas right now
oh my god oh yeah that was so important wasn't it all right
no it wasn't
it's all right yes Yes!
Woo!
Let's
go!
Holland, Holland, ba-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na,
ba-na-na-na-na-na.
Holland, Holland,
ba-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-pom-pom.
Holland, Holland, ba-na-na-na-na-na-na.
I got...
Let's look you go.
Belgium versus USA.
Hey, but hey, Netherlands, hey, no big deal, right?
You got invited to the Premier League.
Isn't that what you wanted?
Isn't it?
It's okay, what you got?
And only three goals, that's right.
Five goals.
All five goals are from me.
No bar in sight.
If you think about it, I've made all five goals
Oh shit, oh Yeah No, no, no, no, no, let me celebrate we did
it Yeah, I scored every goal Yeah!
We did it.
We won.
We helped the Netherlands team make it through the Premier
League too.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Who is Telstar, bro?
Hey, this is a semi-final.
Yes, this is the semis.
I won the Koop the club.
Look at that.
I won.
Oh, yeah!
That was the final.
Yeah!
and it comes in style on the big stage whoa and now this is
really special isn't it the chance to run with that trophy
over towards the fans what a comeback what a fuck who the
fuck is Nico Gonzalez a fucking winner that's who they
certainly have and the players greatly appreciate A fucking
winner.
Oh, yeah.
First time playing, won the champions.
I'm so good at football.
Guys, look at 31 shots.
103 passes attempted.
It's the stats, by the way.
For those who can't see it.
These are the stats.
What a match.
31 shots.
103 passes.
64.
30 tackles.
Alright, wait.
all right eight points i need to know the highlighter best
moment i want i think i think this was my best moment
it's beautiful that was a i think i did really well oh it's
in and it goes down as a known goal by the keeper.
It's so costly.
Save.
Oh, I have to use the recording tool.
And it goes down as a known goal by the keeper.
Truly, guys, record this.
Oh my god, look at that beautiful goal.
Oh, it's in.
And it goes down as a known goal by the keeper.
It was, it was.
My mouse was connected.
I didn't know how to fucking move.
I couldn't move.
What is that?
That's where I'm gaming.
Clip it and ship it.
All right, what are some of the best moments?
Oh, yeah, that was good.
That was a good moment.
I'm ready for the big leagues.
I think I'm I'm a gamer right there This is gonna go viral
Yeah, go
I submit that like guys clip in and I'll tag Manchester City
look at that guys i think i may or may not be a natural at
football i'm peeking right there but oh my god um um they
made it to the finals it's not low tier they literally made
it to the finals guys all right i'm gonna call it here all
right all right guys i'm gonna call it here We had, there
was everything.
There was cats.
We had cats.
We have football.
We had...
We played video games, guys.
I told you we're gonna play a video game.
We had cats.
We had football.
We had art of the deal.
We had negotiations.
We had, we had, uh, Hollandham.
We had four packages of cats.
went on strike yeah real gamers don't do the tutorial i
learned on the fly we had holland dark plate thank you super
chat thank you thank you games way over ball goals needed to
be reviewed by far var and they decided to have to reverse
him for all of the fouls in the build-up except the own goal
thank you the super chat dark plate thank you this stream
had everything guys it had everything
I hope you enjoyed whatever the fuck this stream was.
I'm sorry we didn't play more cats, but I realized, like, if
I knew this was a multiplayer, I would have made, I would
have set up a collab for it.
Next time, next time we're going to make a collab stream out
of it.
Because I feel like it'd be much more fun if I got a bunch
of, like, if I get four people to play it, to work at the
post office with me.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture
check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
Head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Oh, yeah.
Secret ending.
I forgot to mention about it, but I uploaded the waiting
room for the new outfit reveal on Saturday, guys.
It's up, guys.
Oh, wait, where is it?
But yeah, yeah.
Pajama outfit reveal on Saturday, guys.
what for those who don't follow me on Twitter or saw
anything about it yeah Saturdays they hype hype hype hype
but actually I have like sort of like nothing really
prepared special prepared other than me I think well other
than me I think I'm special other than my presence I guess
that's special enough I guess that's secret ending did I
show the silhouette on stream I did right I don't remember
it.
Yeah, I did.
A reminder.
Oh, my God.
This is a big image.
Here's the silhouette, guys.
Look.
I sure am.
Especially after the FIFA performance.
Oh, yes.
Yay.
Yeah.
Can't wait to have another new outfit on Saturday.
Yep.
Anyway, guys, bye-bye, everybody.
Bye.